well then what was your biggest big job
you were on a show that I was my
favorite show for years which is the
tutors oh gosh yes yeah it's like just
sex and corsets basically which is
pretty cool yeah that's a great shirt
that I yeah that was probably I don't
know I mean I was like five so it's like
a big McVitie's commercial when I was
like seven can we see that on YouTube
actually you can well what's a god
the McVitie's I don't know if you have
brown hair is a biscuit put it the right
durable but then you did it but what was
it like I cuz I'm sorry for asking but
working with Spielberg yeah you don't
like you only ask I just mentioned the
name Jimmy that would be like for about
five seconds what what else is there
that dude he's the nicest man he's so
sweet and yeah and like really fun and
just lovely and I unfortunately I cried
in front of him which was really really
embarrassing it was a lot of pain why
because in the scene and ready pay one
there's a dancing scene and we're like
but we were all in harnesses and I don't
know if you've ever worn one of those
but it's so [ __ ] painful and then and
I had to keep dropping down but like I
kept hitting my knees and I was just
like I was utterly black and blue after
after my like after that day of filming
and I'm I person to tears and it was he
sympathetic yes yeah so I just felt like
such a [ __ ] I was just like you know I'm
tired and feeling --mode terrible but
he's great and then I actually really
loved the movie yeah I mean like you
know I love
that movie no I saw the movie too I love
it my it's my nephew's favorite movie
pretty like it's a great movie alright
thanks I want to ask him about this
[ __ ] guy right here but this bro
right here this Brad do you a 9/11 movie
my dude just told me about that I need
haven't you haven't seen it
oh I love that movie with Nicholas Kate
the Nicolas Cage one is it yeah pin yeah
yeah like you don't like him no he's
great why did you whisper Michael Pena I
don't know I think she was afraid it
wasn't him it was like the other brown
guy like Danny Trejo yes can I just tell
you my opinion about I can't tell them
what my opinion by Michael I say so
there was a time why you were
whisperings because you knew that Bobby
is that back in the day we I would say
hi to him and you're very friendly but
then once then he blew up I started
becoming successful and then I saw him
at fresh brothers I said walk up and I
go what's up dude right and he kind of
looked at me and then he just kind of
went back into his meal with his family
I just needed that was it your approach
know that what's up dude as a little
girl I was a little too hard I'll show
you exactly how about be real you're
Michael Pena okay George
hey what's up man okay no he didn't do
that he went and then I don't know why
but when that happens I just switch off
you know and I start eating I don't know
why maybe I don't know what went on in
his day maybe had a hard day and I'm
reading it wrong maybe it's me it's
probably [ __ ] me yeah it's me
sometimes day yeah I don't know it's
like there was some other [ __ ] that came
up right before you got that was like oh
your Blue Slide my face yeah yeah yeah
yeah I mean you were just happen to be
this guy and he Pony didn't eat he's
just like oh so we don't know what like
you know like you know when I when my
dad died in August I remember some guy
came up I was walking on Saturday and
some guy said hi to me that I knew and I
was just so just in trauma just
traumatized I didn't even say anything I
just walked by and then he might think
you know man so you don't know what
people think so Michael Pena I'd like
him again I like him again so Mike
progress progress guys Michael we you
know we got these guys on the podcast
due to do the podcast you may come next
to me tiger belly the fresh brother but
when so when you were Oliver Stone
directed that yeah see that's another
one where I just be like holy [ __ ] was
he nice he was a trim he's like very
smart guy
very thoughtful obviously he has like
you know he's got a crazy film directing
career